量子重ね合わせを測定するのはコインを投げるのと同じくらいランダムだが、その例えはどこまで通用するのか
そして、どこで破綻するのか。今日はkiss in the classroomで確かめていく
kiss in the classroomへようこそ。量子コンピューティング関連のコースで出会う基本概念を分かりやすく解説する動画シリーズだ
各動画には説明欄にリンクされたインタラクティブモジュールがついているので、ぜひそちらも確認してほしい。今日のテーマは量子論の核心にある基本原理の一つ、
重ね合わせだ。日常の経験では、物体は常に確定した特徴を持っている。場所、大きさ、
形、色——あらゆる性質が決まっていて確実だ。私たち観測者がまだ測定していなくても。しかし量子の
世界では、必ずしもそうではない。量子オブジェクトは、重ね合わせと呼ばれる状態にあり得る——
古典的に許された複数の状態の重ね合わせで、測定するとそのうちの一つにランダムに収縮する
重ね合わせ状態の測定はコインを投げるのに似ている。事前にどちらに落ちるか知ることはできない
この根本的な不確定性は量子力学の不快な側面で、Einsteinでさえ受け入れに苦労した
彼はこのランダム性について「神はサイコロを振らない」と有名な言葉を残したが、これから見ていくように、神は実際にサイコロを振る——あるいはこの
場合はコインを投げる。しかもそのコインはイカサマだ。量子重ね合わせの測定はコインを投げることに似ているが、
重ね合わせそのものははるかに豊かで複雑で、古典的な
確率的な状態とは全く違う。これを理解するために、古典的なコインの仕組みを考えて、
IBM量子コンピューターでqubitを使って探求する量子コインと対比してみよう
まず古典的なコインだ。シンプルで、コインを投げるとどちらか表か裏に50%の確率で落ちる。理論的には、コインの正確な初期条件と
投げるときに加えられた力とトルクを正確に知っていれば、どちらに落ちるか計算できる
しかし実際には、事前にどちら側に落ちるか知ることはできない。だからこそ
コイン投げを古典的な確率的状態の典型例として使う——
結果が本質的にランダムな場合だ。このコインを千回投げて、表と
裏の回数を記録すると、このようなヒストグラムが得られる。Y軸にカウント数があり、
表か裏のどちらかで、
ヒストグラムにはそれぞれ約500カウントが示される——
統計的なゆらぎはあるが。量子コンピューターでqubitを使って同様の状態を作れる。コイン投げと同様に、
qubitも0と1の2つの状態で測定できる。qubitにHadamardゲートを適用すると、
0と1の等しい重ね合わせ状態になる。これがそのcircuitの
可視化——circuitダイアグラムと呼ぶ。一番上のワイヤがqubitで、qubitに適用される操作はワイヤ上のボックスとして表示される。Hadamardゲートはこの
Hとラベルされたボックスで示され、測定はこの小さな測定記号でラベルされたグレーのボックスで示される。それは
測定を古典的なビットに送る——2本線のワイヤだ。qubitは0と1の等しい重ね合わせにあるため、
測定すると50%の確率で0、50%で1が測定される
この量子重ね合わせ状態はs = 1/
√2 |0⟩ + 1/√2 |1⟩と表現される。各
係数（振幅とも呼ばれる）の2乗が各状態を測定する確率だ。つまりHadamardゲートを適用することはコインを投げることのアナログで、ちょうどコインを千回投げて
表か裏の統計を調べたように、KCSETで量子コインを使って同様のことができる
Qiskitのprimitiveであるsamplerを使い、circuitを何度も繰り返してその統計をサンプリングする
上のcircuitの千サンプルで、統計的なゆらぎを除いて古典的なコインのヒストグラムとほぼ同一のものが得られる。では量子
重ね合わせは本質的に古典的な確率的状態と同じで、コインを投げることに似ているのか。そうではない。もし
そうなら、これはかなり短い動画になっていただろう。最初の重要な違いを見るために、古典的なコインで少し違うことを試してみる。
コインを単純にテーブルに落として表か裏に落ちるのではなく、コインを投げて
両手の間で宙でキャッチする。するとコインは表でも裏でもなく、代わりに左向きか
右向きのどちらかだ。論理的に考えると、これも50/50の確率で
左か右になるはずだ。量子コインで左向きか右向きを測定するには、古典的なコインと同じことができる——
異なる軸に沿って測定する。量子コンピューターでの標準的な測定は垂直軸に沿っている——
古典的なコインの通常の表か裏の測定と同様だ。しかし量子コインに左か右かを問うこともできる。
x軸に沿ったこの2つの状態をプラスまたはマイナスと呼ぶ
このためにQiskitのprimitiveであるestimatorを使う。少し複雑になるが、samplerのようにヒストグラムを返す代わりに、
estimatorはqubitの任意の観測量の期待値を返す。
この期待値を理解するために、コインが表に落ちるたびに1ドル得て、裏に落ちると1ドル失うとしよう。
期待値は、コイン投げごとに平均してどれだけ稼げるかだ。1ドル得るか失うかは等しく、
期待値は0になる。同じ論理をqubitに適用できる。xの期待値を求めると、プラス状態にxを適用すると
+1の値が得られ、マイナス状態には-1が得られる。
50/50の分布なら期待値は0になるはずだが、そうではない。期待値は+1になる——
つまりコインはx軸に沿って常にプラスと測定される。それはコインを
投げてキャッチして、頭が常に右を向くことを保証するようなものだ。これは
qubitに適用する。xの期待値を求めると、プラス状態にxを適用すると
+1の値が得られ、マイナス状態には-1が得られる。つまり50/50なら
期待値は0になるはずだが、そうではない。期待値は+1になる
つまりコインはx軸に沿って常にプラスと測定される。それはコインを
投げてキャッチして、頭が常に右を向くことを保証するようなものだ。これは
重ね合わせが単なる確率分布ではないためだ。量子
状態sはC0×|0⟩+C1に等しい
* 状態1で、これらの係数がそれぞれ複素数であるということ——つまり
実部と虚部の両方を持つということだ。確率について教えてくれるだけでなく、「位相」と呼ばれる別の量も内包している
位相とは何か。ある係数Cはこのように書ける——
CはC = 大きさ × 位相という形で表され、このφが
位相だ。波の位相、つまり波の山と谷の位置に似ている。2つの波が同位相の場合
——山と谷が揃っている場合——それらは重なり合って2倍の高さの波を作る
これを「建設的干渉」と呼ぶ。逆位相の場合——
このような場合——「破壊的干渉」が起き、完全に打ち消し合う。位相がどのように干渉を引き起こすか見るために
量子コインで試してみよう。Hadamardを一度だけでなく二度適用してみる。古典的な世界では
これは意味をなさない——Hadamardの適用がコインを投げることと同等なら、既に投げているコインをもう一度投げることはできない。でも量子力学的に何が
起きるか見てみよう。Hadamardを2回適用して、結果の状態をサンプリングする
驚くことに、もう50/50の確率ではない。ヒストグラムを見ると、あらゆるケースで
qubitがゼロ状態にあると測定される。つまり2回目のHadamardがqubitを開始時のゼロ状態に戻した。これは
最初は少しわかりにくいが、量子状態の干渉のおかげだ。ただし
実際の波のように実空間で干渉するのではなく、qubitの抽象的な情報空間で干渉が起きている
2回目のHadamard gateが、重ね合わせのゼロ部分を建設的に干渉させ、1の部分を
破壊的に干渉させて消滅させた。さらに探求してみよう——「phase gate」と呼ばれるものを使って位相を変えられる
重ね合わせを作るためにHadamardを適用し、πラジアンの位相シフトを加え
その後2回目のHadamardを適用する。すると量子コインは常に1の状態になるように見える
πの位相シフトが、同位相と逆位相にあった重ね合わせ状態の部分を入れ替えた
だから最終状態はゼロではなく1になる。これはコインを投げ、空中にある間に
何らかの操作を加えて、常に表が出るか常に裏が出るかを保証できるようなものだ——どの
操作をするかによって。古典的な場合には不可能だが、量子の場合は違う。これらの実験から学んだのは
量子コインのこの新しい能力は位相によるものだということ——量子の重ね合わせが持つが、
古典的な確率分布には存在しない性質だ。だから通常のコイン投げは実は重ね合わせの
あまり良い例えではない——この位相については何も教えてくれないから。もっと良い例えができると思う。別の
実験をやってみよう。コインをテーブルの上に表を上にして置く。裏にするには単に裏返せばいい。これは
NOTゲートと計算上同等だ。では2回適用するとこのNOTゲートと同等になる操作を構築したいとする
その操作を「NOTの平方根」と呼ぼう。物理的に何をしているか考えてみよう
NOTゲートを適用するとき、例えばx軸周りに180°回転させている。コインを
x軸周りに90°だけ回転させれば、NOTの平方根になる。これを適用すると
コインはちょうどエッジの上に立った状態になる。これは表か裏か？
明らかにどちらでもない。でも測定プロセスにステップを加えて、表か裏かに強制できる。すると
コインは等確率で表か裏のどちらかに倒れる。原理的には倒れる方向を予測できるが
実際にはランダムと言えるほど難しい。左右どちらに倒れるか
測定したい場合、その方向に押しつぶして同様にすると、また
50/50の確率で左右どちらかになる。でもこの次元では——前か後ろか——
頭は既に前を向いているので、100%の確率で前向きと測定される。つまりxとz方向の
測定はランダムな結果をもたらすが、y方向の測定は常に同じ結果をもたらす。前のセクションの
量子コイン投げの実験を思い返すと、これはHadamardを適用した後の量子コインの振る舞いに
似ている——qubitはz方向に50/50の確率でゼロか1に測定されたが
x方向には常にプラス状態で、マイナス状態には決してならなかった。これは、エッジで静止しているコインが
空中で激しく回転するコインよりも、qubitの重ね合わせ状態をよりよく可視化できる方法かもしれない
QiskitでqubitのコインにNOTの平方根gateを適用してみよう。このシンプルな
circuitがある。次にestimatorを使って、3つの観測量X、Y、Zの期待値を確認する——これらは
コインを3次元の各方向に潰すようなものだ。期待値は0、
-1、0——X、Y、Zについてそれぞれ。これは古典的なコインにNOTの平方根の回転を
適用した場合と同じ結果だ。実際、コインとqubit状態の間には精密な対応関係がある
qubitの状態を、コインの頭の方向を指すベクトルとして可視化できる
コインの表面に垂直なベクトルだ。表向き——ゼロ状態——は
真上を指すベクトルに相当し、裏向き——1状態——は真下を指す。そして
ゼロと1の等しい重ね合わせは水平方向を指す。量子状態の位相が正確な水平
方向を決める——例えばx軸に沿うのか、y軸に沿うのか、その
中間なのか。このベクトルは「Blochベクトル」として知られており、単一の
qubitの量子状態を完全かつ一意に決定する。これでこの動画で見てきたすべてのgateを
コイン上の、あるいは同等にBlochベクトル上の回転として再解釈できる。NOTゲートは
x軸周りの180°の回転だ。ゼロ状態——表向き——に適用すると
裏向き——1状態——に裏返る。NOTの平方根は同じx軸周りの90°だ。
表向き状態からこれを適用すると、前向きに回転する。phase gateはz軸周りのφの回転だ。
表向きはz軸と揃っているので、コインには何もしない。Hadamard gateは少し複雑で
最初はコインを投げてコントロールできない回転をさせることに例えたが、実際にはHadamardは
コインのコントロールされた決定論的な回転のように、他のすべてのgateと同じく、HadamardはY軸を中心に90°回転させることで実行される
次にX軸を中心に180°回転させる。だから表向きの状態に適用すると、
表向き右になる。つまり量子重ね合わせ状態にはランダムな要素は何もなく、
qubitに対して行う標準的な操作にも同様だ。すべての操作は決定論的かつ可逆的で、
ランダム性が生じるのは量子状態を測定することを決めた時だけだ。量子状態が重ね合わせ状態にあるかどうかは
本当に見る者の目次第だ。おそらく知っている通り、座標系は自由に選べる。
X、Y、Zは任意の3つの直交方向を向けることができる。だから
ある座標系で0と1の重ね合わせがある場合、新しい座標系、いわゆる
新しい基底を定義でき、その基底では状態は純粋に+Z方向を向いていて、重ね合わせ状態ではなくなる。
だからqubitが重ね合わせ状態にあると言う時は、座標系、つまり
基底も定義しなければならない。このモジュールを終えると、量子力学からすべての謎を取り除いたという印象を受けるかもしれない。
なぜなら、最も奇妙とされてきた側面の一つ、qubitの重ね合わせ状態が本当にただの
三次元ベクトルのように単純だからだ。しかし、コインはあくまでも類比であり、ブロッホベクトルでさえも
測定結果の確率を計算するための可視化ツールにすぎないことを忘れないでほしい。測定前に量子
状態が実際に何をしているかは言えない。それを確認するには測定が必要だからだ。この
量子状態の真の性質とは何かという難問、そして量子もつれがどう
解明に役立つかについては、Bellの不等式をテーマにしたkisdの教室の別のエピソードで議論する。それまでの間、
qubitの重ね合わせ状態について自分で学び、どうコントロールするかを知るために量子コインで遊びたいなら、
説明欄にリンクされているquantum coinsモジュールに行ってみてほしい。視聴してくれてありがとう、また次回会おう。